jetzt probieren wir unseren trick aus ob
das geht kann das sein dass wir jetzt
es sollte eigentlich funktionieren dass
wir jetzt hier drauf uns quasi es ist so
bitter servus kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
machen heute was besonderes und sparen
und zwar spielen wir heute nicht mal
complete wir schauen uns auch nicht dem
murphy bord an sondern wie spielen heute
eine rätsel map die rezepte gletscher
und da geht es darum in sieben
verschiedenen levels sich quasi
durchzublicken für jedes level hat in
eigene minecraft bridge die man kennen
muss und anwenden muss um es zu schaffen
die map ist ziemlich neu für die 194 der
download links und einer beschreibung
ich hab die bei dem amerikanischen die
tür entdeckt dass wir mal keine ahnung
warum problem dass niemand aus für
deutschland genau so willing lust
bringen die welt rein und raus fast
alles klar
bei comand blogs von player only
difficulties so als ob erlaubt sind
wir wollten den kommerz ergebnis heißt
schützen aktiviert das heißt command
boxleitner funktionieren ein spieler
okay wir sind alleine difficulty haben
wir game o2 haben wir und views of the
block die hand is always the finish spot
alles klasse die die goldene ist immer
das ziel des safe punkte speicherpunkt
und der kurs von 100% possible adwords
testet also man kann den kurs auf jeden
fall schaffen
sagen sie das getestet haben mca das
hier gebaut
mein fifty two productions ich bin sehr
gespannt
leute ich konnte bisher nur blog löschen
aber jetzt geht's orte glitches pack mas
okay so das erste level habe ich schon
gesehen deswegen tue ihr doch nicht so
was noch nie gespielt weil auch
lächerlich so es geht nämlich darum dass
wenn man hier lang läuft
man instant stirbt man fällt instant aus
der welt wenn ihr lang läuft so zac hat
was okay das kann ich stimme alles klar
auf jeden fall ist er trägt dass man
hier einfach hier raus liegen was guckt
so da läuft man auf der kante kannte man
läuft ihr mann läuft eigentlich noch den
bock drauf hinter genau hinschaut seht
ihr dass wir gar nicht auf dem bock
drauf laufen so so kann man schaffen
man kommt hier über über diese tödlichen
blöcke hinweg und kommt auf diese dinge
drauf wenn sie beim nächsten alles klar
ok aha so was muss man hier machen
okay das sieht nicht so gut aus das
sieht da es dafür bin ich ein bisschen
groß für die tür glaube ich okay ja kann
auch nichts abbauen
ok ich glaub muss man achten muss man
den nice hat es gesehen da muss diesen
cutting edge benutzen um sich irgendwie
hoch zu backen das level habe ich
nämlich schon nicht mehr gesehen habe -
erst lange schaut so dass hier war jetzt
vollkommen frei sarah ich als gute
ausdauer checkpoint sehr gut das ging
schnell
und es geht direkt weiter ok offen offen
offen wir brauchen welche indizien lang
zu kommen ok ok große tour
was ist das
sie kann man sich hier vielleicht
irgendwie durch die wand klatschen wenn
man sich den links dagegen geht's haut
gegen kopf dieses ding wir rocken heute
übrigens wieder in hemd falls es nicht
gesehen habe und das passt farblich
sogar zum mikro alter zu krass berg
aufgetürmt ist okay also müssen wir
irgendwie aus der bude raus vielleicht
hilft zwar nicht einfach robben
geräuschemacher dass man ihr wenn ihr
einfach geräusch mache die einer robbe
emittieren vielleicht löst sich dann das
trikot von selbst einfach mal wie kommen
wir hier raus also ich muss auf jeden
fall ich die tür gehen hier oder
also ich kann nichts abbauen so dass
hier bringt uns überhaupt nicht
verstehen dass es den kopf hauen und tut
ein bisschen weh aber hat er verändert
sich wirklich was ich habe keine ahnung
hatte
ich musste joker einsetzen okay okay
leute ich habe mir einen kleinen tipp
kodieren das fundraising geschaut nimmt
die map schon mal gespielt wurde und auf
dem fairplay ist das bett deswegen
vermutlich einfach mal dass so etwas wie
tibet zu tun hat und okay obwohl da was
kommt mit dem bett groß machen
man kann sich reinlegen schlafen
schlafen schlafen und wenn man jetzt auf
steht ist man draußen leute von dem
gletscher dich selber noch überhaupt
keine ahnung alter krass das habe ich
auf jeden fall schon mal neu dazu
gelernt den kakteen glück kann ich auch
nicht aber den kann ich mir noch denken
aber davon hatte ich einfach überhaupt
keine ahnung ok nächstes level drei von
sieben mal geschafft so ok ich glaube
ach das ist ja ok den glitch den kennt
man ja einfach hier oben drauf laut ok
der kiez war dann wieder total die sie
also von dem mit dem bett hatte ich
überhaupt keine ahnung aber der hier ist
ja mega sie einfach hier diese teppich
auf einem zaun glitsch da wird man quasi
dann ein halb oder eher ein halb blöcke
oder irgendwas hoch gewicht und kann man
ja einfach hier drüben auf die gold
platte gehen vier von sieben geschafft
und jetzt haben wir das problem dass
hier irgendwas kaputt gehe sehr boden
tötet alles kalr bodentypen wir dann
können wir natürlich unfallschaden okay
wie kann man das jetzt machen megageil
im web muss ich sagen die macht mega
bock das richtig gut man kann im spiel
ein bisschen rätsel und lernten was okay
ja oh wunder wer hätte gedacht dass es
hier lang gehen könnte ok jiji
okay wie soll man ist der hier überhaupt
noch zu schaffen
der ist noch zu schaffen aber wie wieso
man den hier was uns fahrer block in der
mitte auf jemand aufspringen kann oder
so vielleicht von von dem aus einfach
hier so walter okay okay also hier da
drauf kommt man alle guten tagen an
schlechten tagen kann manchmal darauf so
hier
pam pam pam pam pam so er sagt da lang
aber ganz ehrlich wieviel vertrauen kann
mit diesem schild schenken so jetzt sind
wir hier drauf und jetzt ist die frage
wie zur hölle gibt es hier irgendwo in
unsichtbaren blog aber das ist es dann
gilt wenn es einfach ein unsichtbarer
blog ist nein oder ok vielleicht das ist
wirklich irgend was hier einspringen lol
lol lol lol habt ihr das gesehen dass
das schild ist das schild selbst ein
blog wir konnten auf dem schild
geradestehen soll geht es seit wann geht
das
ich hatte überhaupt keine ahnung ist das
ist es weit bekannt oder so ihr könnt
ihr mal in die kommentare schreiben
obwohl die gauchos alle schon kannte
oder welchen hafenkante den hier kann
sich auf jeden fall nicht und ich habe
auch nicht gespoilert so ehrlich bin ich
mit euch dass ich das sei aber nicht
spoilern aber das wusste ich echt nicht
und so kommen natürlich easy rüber und
haben dann glaube ich den fünften von
sieben geschafft
so jetzt die frage wo geht's hier dann
dreht sich um den baum
ich hätte ja richtig packen auf seinem
blog blitzsauber abbauen ist irgendwie
verboten hier
ok hallo kann ich kurz da ein ich muss
kurz auf diesen blog da dürfte ich kurz
einfach weiter wie geht das denn
steht man hier auf den dingen höher
niemand steht auf diesen dings labs
nicht höher als auf dem normalen schnee
es heißt also die bringt auch gar nicht
so viel und hier selbe sache bei einer
normalen merkwürdig davon ausgehen dass
hier irgendwo irgendwas versteckt ist
aber man kann schnell auch nicht abbauen
aber hier ist ja einfach nichts
versteckt dann besser auch kein blick
mehr wenn man irgendwie irgendwas
auslösen müsste
moment mal da unten kann man durch sehen
dass irgendwas bedeuten
man muss ja irgendwie hier oben drauf
kommen ach moment mal kommen die pisten
kann man vielleicht auch hier dann geht
es vielleicht gar nicht direkt darum
wenn es hier pisten sind kann man die
vielleicht durch den tunnel der hier
drüben beginnt irgendwie auslösen
geht es hier oben irgendwo rein also da
sehen wir so ein spalt durch ne ich weiß
nicht was das zu bedeuten hat hier
vielleicht irgendwas klicken
ich weiß nicht es muss eigentlich hier
sein da unten ich glaube ist dass
entscheider und ich glaube das ist ein
schalter oder also dass wir jetzt
gespielt habe sagt dass man hier
irgendwie an diesen schalter ankommen
muss what the [ __ ] wie wir haben es
verbockt und seht ihr es als klar der
studenten in seoul
oh mein gott aber wie gesagt ehrlichkeit
währt am längsten da habe ich habe ich
gespürt hab gesehen dass man tatsächlich
selten sich irgendwie neu positionieren
muss um diesen schalter auszulösen
oh mein gott ich habe aber nicht
aufgepasst das ist schon die längste ich
kann leider nicht zählen
okay hier kommen wir auf jeden fall hoch
ok scheinbar da oben sind goldbecker
also wird irgendwo da oben dass das ende
sein gehirn redstone krasniqis der
ameisen spitzhacke glasflasche
glasflaschen mit falls wir mal
zwischendurch durchkriegen fäden und
eine menge menge menge menge menge
eichenholz alles klar
sowas können machen wir zum beispiel
eine angel machen können damit zum
beispiel einen bogen machen okay wir
haben wir braust ende press tour ist
alles klar damit kann man sich resetten
ja wie sowie vier blöcke sind das ist
ein vielleicht 15 blöcke und wir haben
26 eichenholz okay ich mache jetzt
einfach mal ach man kann keine blöcke
platzieren um ein grad kann man
vielleicht auf dem auf den links
platzieren
kann man auch nicht okay was können wir
damit jetzt machen wir können uns zum
beispiel eine angel machen r
wirtschaftsverfahren soll jetzt einfach
hier so und einfach endlos fischer an
den moment mal kannst das sein dass man
dass man sich hier irgendwas angel muss
um da rauszukommen ist die wegen der
baustelle defektes man sich irgendwie an
fust forschen macht eine hasenphobie
oder kommen sich allerdings hasen angeln
im himmel anleger eine schüssel geangelt
erst mal ausprobieren könnte leute ist
man die anleihen nach oben wirft und
dass ich da irgendwie selbst pustet aber
das sind halt auch nur das sind keine
sechs blöcke die man damit macht kommen
blöcke abbauen
ja aber nur den redstone und warum
dropped 1 1 redstone ärzten redstone
blog den platzieren den komplizieren
okay und ich weiß echt nicht weiter ich
glaube ich hole mir maria ein tipp 1
er ist es so krass ich bin 20 minuten
hier ich weiß einfach nicht weiter weg
also die mehr bericht recht
anspruchsvoll
sechseinhalb stunden später mein gott
leute es ist so verdammt hart wie wie in
seinem leben sommer drauf kommen passt
auf die sache ist nämlich wir müssen
resetten so wenn wir uns jetzt hier die
pixel zack bumm mit der px den block
abbauen dann liegt der red star und er
gibt uns obwohl red schon auf dem boden
liegt im redstone blog und jetzt ist der
trick wer soll da drauf kommen scheinbar
ist der server so programmiert dass er
immer wenn redstone erz auf dem boden
liegt im spiel im redstone blog gibt und
das heißt natürlich wie man jetzt hier
quasi daraus neuen rats märz macht
kriegt man für jedes letztes man dropped
gesetz und im inventar einen redstone
blog rein und kann sich quasi so
unendlich redstone machen und noch ein
ding was ich nicht gesehen habe ist die
redstone blöcke können nur auf
speziellen blöcken platziert werden
entweder auf redstone blocken oder auf
stein ziegeln so und das hier sind ja
stein ziege es probieren wir unseren
trick aus ob das geht kann das sein dass
wir jetzt
es sollte eigentlich funktionieren dass
wir jetzt hier drauf uns quasi es ist so
bitter das ding gewonnen leute das war
der letzte rettung so trat aber leute
die map hat mir richtig gut gefallen wie
gesagt schreibt in die kommentare welche
glitches erkannte seit mit euch selbst
ehrlich seid mit uns ehrlich schreibt
ehrlich sein welche gekannt habe welche
nicht wer spaß zu sehen
auf jeden fall bis zum nächsten mal laut
rhein macht's gut